and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we got a special guest today
indeed we do welcome to episode 158
today we're gonna talk about self care
and we've got one of my favorite human
beings in the world here Randi Kaye from
the simple self care podcast
yeah man welcome to the show thanks for
having me thanks for joining us
so Randy is from Fargo North Dakota yes
I does that place actually exists or is
it just in the movies we've not been too
far gone forever man but yeah that is uh
what a beautiful city it's one of my top
10 cities for sure really is culture per
capita there is insane we just tend not
to go there in the winter or the summer
yeah there's like a dozen days and
throughout the year where you go there
and you're like oh my god I want to move
here yeah but there is a lot of like
like you said culture per capita it's
it's a very big small town and we were
first exposed to that because we Ryan
and I and our friend Colin who we were
running the publishing company with at
the time we all lived in Missoula so
this was 2013 we were asked to come
speak at a conference that's where we
first met you was this conference called
misfit Colin and we'd turned them down
like we do most conferences right we
turned in columns one who talked us into
doing it like come on guys well I don't
know because at that play yeah you were
you were the lead and they play yeah it
was like yeah it was opening weekend I
was doing that play but but man when you
guys came back you and Colin came back
and you were just a static about how
awesome Fargo was and I was like God
like I want to go to this conference
next year and it was mainly because of
Randi Kaye right exactly no it is today
we're about self-care Randy how do how
do we define self-care and how do we do
so in a way that isn't off-putting to
someone like me are you gonna pull out
crystals I got with him Abed
so so Kara starts with crystals yeah no
you know it's a very good question and
self-care has actually become kind of an
annoying word I think right because it's
associated with a lot more superficial
things like take a bubble bath or did it
and those things are great but that's
only kind of scratching the surface so
yeah I mean this sort of when I think of
self-care I often think of those like
right exfoliate at the spa and what's
they have these the they're like blow
dry bars here what's that called
blowouts yeah
dude I there's one like right down the
street from a lake Cortney Carver she
was when she was in LA last time she was
like and I was like what is a blow and
she's like you know like and I was like
oh your hair does look awesome she was
like Ryan you should totally go and get
a blowout I think it when it stops right
there then then it's like it's like
trying to take some sort of pill to cure
your whatever it's a short term I need a
short-term fix but when we talk about
self-care I think you're when you focus
on it you're also focused a lot more on
on looking inward yeah so I define it as
the act of tuning in and then acting
accordingly and so these superficial
acts can be ways to relax yourself and
like switch up if you're having a crazy
day right and then you're feeling
anxious and then you're like oh I have
an essential oil that calms me down
and so you take a whiff and then kind of
like changes things yeah and it's like
that is a really simple like soup these
things are okay like you're not saying
superficial pejoratively like it yeah I
mean like it's just like maybe like the
first level you know like it's it's
something different that you can do and
going to the spa like I feel like fits
underneath the self-care umbrella
there's a time and place for that but if
if you use that as an escape that's a
different thing
you know so self can escape it's it's in
a way the opposite of yeah it's like a
gateway it's like whatever it is that
you can do that allows you to like say
hi to yourself and remember that you're
there and that you're breathing and like
oh actually this
thing that I'm doing is causing me
anxiety or this thing that I'm doing
really brings me joy in a way I didn't
really realize so it's a bunch of things
it's different for everybody but it's I
think self-care is just a good term for
that but it's kind of taking on its own
beast these days cuz people are catching
on with the marketing and all this stuff
and it's very bad it's a very broad term
it's like kind of like minimalism I mean
it's it's very broad it's a very broad
term yeah I knew minimalism had jumped
the shark in a way when I walked by like
the gaff and it had shirts to just hit
minimalism on them I'm like if it was a
minimalist shirt you just wouldn't have
a word on the front right doesn't even
make sense
yeah so I like what you just said it but
it way to say hi to yourself so in a way
it's acknowledging you for who you are
acknowledging your thoughts looking
inward because quite often we get caught
up in the the neuroses of everyday
living and the endless rumination and
there's a study recently we were talking
about this on our Aston asked the
minimalist anything live podcast for our
patreon supporters recently and what I
realized was that this endless
rumination there are some scientific
studies now dr. Rhonda Patrick are you
familiar with her she has a great
podcast that I mean she really goes into
the weeds and I mean it's one of those
things you have to like put on 80% speed
and then like take copious notes in
order to understand it she had another
scientists on there who studies
depression and there is a link not
necessarily direct link but a subset of
the depressive people we'll put a link
to this episode in the show notes where
she talks about depression there's a
link between inflammation and and
depression and rumination yeah and so
one of the things that leads to
inflammation is rumination not just
standard thinking we all have to think
about our problems have to think to
prepare for a podcast like this but the
rumination of of sitting up at night in
bed or whirring whirring whirring leads
to inflammation in the body and they're
able to prove this now scientifically
which then of course leads to sadness
depression etc and one of the ways to
combat that is to sort of pause for a
second and
say hey I need to notice what I'm going
through so that I can take care of
myself and and that's that's really
where the self-care comes in yeah
because a lot of these feelings we have
like whether it's anxiety or whether
it's fear I mean these are their
symptoms right so when we have symptoms
like that it's yeah checking in with
yourself and understanding like oh like
I have anxiety that means something
maybe something needs to change
well what needs to change is is the
question like I'll give you an example
yesterday Randy I was I was feeling
super anxious yesterday afternoon and I
know I didn't get a lot of sleep the
night before which I've been doing great
in terms of sleep recently but let the
the night before was just a wasn't
anomaly and and so I can probably link
it to that directly but what do you do
in a situation like that were and I know
you work with a lot of people that who
experience anxiety when someone is
feeling anxious like I was yesterday
afternoon late so the point where I was
getting angry and and anger is not a
typical emotion that I I mean you know
me pretty well I you can't imagine me
like getting it wanting to throw
something but I I felt that way and yeah
I'm I'm able to sort of repress that
emotion we were joking before the
podcast started like what was my memoir
title the power of the power of
repression that Ryan was saying is like
that the thing that differentiates us
from chimpanzees the fact that we can
repress really what he was saying is you
don't have to act on some of these
emotions and so noticing it obviously
yesterday but I felt super anxious what
do you what do you talk to someone about
if they're if they're feeling anxious
what are some things to do
yeah I mean I a few things one thing
when you when you get to the anxious
state it's almost you're almost a little
too far gone at that point yeah so you
have like some of your rituals or things
that you know you like to do that calm
you down like for me it is deep
breathing or like I travel I was
traveling here from South America
yesterday and it was a little stressful
and I just had that like almost a mantra
like you can reel
you can calm down just like kind of
talking to yourself in which which helps
um but I think with anything that comes
up regularly like depression and anxiety
and things like that I like to look at
it as becoming friends with it and so
when it comes up being like hey what are
you doing here and how did you get here
and like do you want to hang out okay
cool now you can go you know and it's
instead of being like oh my gosh and
feeling anxious not feeling anxious that
I'm feeling anxious and why am i feeling
angry now and now you're rid of this
anxiety push it out it's same thing with
meditation where yeah one of the
mistakes that I often get into with
meditation is as I meditate I'm like get
rid of the thoughts in my head push them
out and it's that's not the point it's
about watching the thoughts see you
saying watch the anxiety watch the the
depression and and learn from it it's
like getting curious because the body is
constantly responding to its
surroundings and trying to give us
warning signs so like pain is a signal
from you know the brain to a part of the
body based on the information that it's
gotten so whether it is like a trauma or
injury sitting a lot or an emotional
response or something your body when
when dysfunction comes up it's really
trying to tell you something
so when anxiety comes up or depression
comes up it's just like yeah and it's
like your shoulder hurting you know and
it's just like like something
something's up yeah exactly so it's nice
to just like as much as you can remember
that and be like okay this is what
happens sometimes why are you here do
your best to work through it but then
but then when you have calmed down a
little bit go back and look at maybe how
you got to that point like what was the
recipe that caused that to bubble up and
start to like course-correct a little
bit or adjust this here and there and
you can probably pinpoint why that ended
up happening you know for me I was able
to say hey I think it's linked directly
to sleep and I don't know Ryan he's been
struggling a lot with sleep recently and
and those mornings where you wake up and
you're both have these like sleep
tracker rings and they just tell us how
bad we sleep right now I just yeah oh it
tells me is that I'm gonna
really really tired human being Brian
this is an anxiety ring my do my average
sleep is like 65 dude it's so much you
shouldn't be alive right now
[Laughter]
not like if I get there are a few times
we were out on tour where I would get a
65 and I feel dead you were the most
durable person I have ever met it's he
was eating a bowl of nails for breakfast
it came in here it's important milk on
it you know I just it's funny though
because it makes me sad because I feel
like how would I be if I was getting
like a 90 sleep score I would be
unstoppable
yeah for me like I have to get above an
80 in order to function it's zero to 100
scale but like it heavily weighs deep
sleep REM sleep and especially the
length of sleep and it seems to me like
you you really struggle with deep sleep
but no those mornings you wake up with a
with a lack of deep sleep or whatever
you feel a noticeable difference whether
it's anger or frustration the easiest
things will frustrate you and it does
that with me too and I think yesterday
that was the problem
yeah man if I get up and I did not have
a good night sleep like I like I could
be making coffee in the ground spill a
little bit and I want to like throw my
coffee mug through the wall and then I
had and I have to check in with myself
and be like Ryan buddy I got this mr.
Rogers voice that kind of talks to me
like it really is like hey Ryan you just
didn't get good sleep it's not that big
of a deal okay relax taking a lot of
deep breaths like that it's so funny how
oxygen is anxieties enemy I feel like
because for me when I get to those
really anxious states like I do check in
and kind of you know appreciate and I
say appreciate as in like just try to
understand why on that where I'm at the
opposite but the but deep breaths man
like really really it just helps me
totally relax dude if I could take ten
deep breaths it's not like this instant
magic cure mm-hmm but it does help me to
just take it down a notch the other
thing too I know I noticed is that if I
feel anxious I will just eat a snack
and I'm not even hungry though I just
feel anxious but then I'll need a snack
and then like nine times out of ten like
that's what it is I was just hungry
didn't even watch sugar yeah yeah I
found for me when I'm anxious like
yesterday I will catch myself on not
breathing at all lay I'll just for I
don't know 30 seconds at a time I'm like
and then I realized like I looked at
Beck's yesterday at one point I said I'm
not breathing right now and I spilt a
glass of water last night and like
riders are going to vet and it
infuriated me and and but I had to do
the same thing I just sort of check in
with myself like hey it's just a glass
of water you can clean this up it's
going to be okay it's not a problem at
all this is not just fixable but when I
pan out for five minutes the problem is
gonna be over with yeah I think the
problem is like when we are in that
anxious state like maybe there is you
know whether it's sleep or maybe there's
you know something personal going on
it's like the little things bother us
because for me at least I feel like when
something little happens like if I spill
a glass of water when I'm a little bit
anxious it's like Jesus Christ I can't
even pour a glass of water right like
it's like this yeah well and this is
where self-care comes in because if you
have a a regular daily practice you have
some reserves for those stressful times
so if you're constantly depleted and
you're stressed out and then something
happens that it's like not taking from
anything so you don't have really a lot
to like cushion or comfort yourself and
so a lot of people you know they when
they feel good they don't really they're
just like I'm feeling good I'm gonna
just carry on with my life but sometimes
we also we try to enhance the good yeah
and we'll turn to things that are like
bad for us whether it's like drugs
alcohol partying staying up late like
whatever it is right you know in a weird
way yeah so it is really important to
keep just
it's like just continuing continually
and nourishing yourself so when you have
a moment or anxiety creeps in you have
something to pull from you have some
reserves there yeah that way I like that
well Randy we have some questions today
we don't we don't do interviews on on
our podcast instead we bring some folks
in occasionally that we like and we help
some folks with their questions and our
first question today is from Shaylee in
Washington State I just wanted to know
if you guys had any advice for moving on
from past versions of yourself
for context I'm figuring out who I am
and who I want to be during my upcoming
senior year and Beyond and I feel held
back by certain expectations that I and
others have for myself based on who I've
been in the past I've struggled with
depression and self-harm
so feeling like I'm stuck there and
can't grow and move past that is
definitely weighing me down
all right so Randy Shaylee says she's
trying to move on from from past
versions of herself
first thing I would say is
congratulations on asking some of the
right questions here instead of just
attempting to continue to struggle
through or push through it it's a very
American tendency or maybe just a
Western tendency for us to like set
aside the problems and think I'm going
to I'm going to just push through them
I'm going to crawl over top of them
instead of going through them and and
and what Shelley is trying to do right
now is try to go through some of those
those problems now she she said
something was interesting to me she said
I'm trying to figure out who I am and
who I want to be and I think we're all
trying to figure out who we are and who
we want to become that's what growth is
right because once you get to the
horizon it's not like all of a sudden
I'm reached the horizon no there's
always going to be a new horizon at
least if you're living a meaningful life
now the problem is we talked to - Pete
Rollins about this we did a podcast
episode about love and he differentiated
pleasure from enjoyment the pleasure is
sort of in the moment like experiencing
of something which can be fine and nice
but enjoyment is the broader
pleasure where it's like anticipating
who we're going to become or
anticipating the activity the vacation
we're going to go on and it's also
reflecting back on the the past
experiences in a way that we're learning
from from our past self so it seems to
me like right now she says she's trying
to move on from her past self but but
aren't we always we're always trying to
move forward and I think I make that I
make that distinction so so what what
advice do you have what words of wisdom
do you have for Shaylee yeah I think
yeah this is a common thing that I think
will come up many times in her life and
in a person's life like you said and so
I think taking the pressure off that you
have to have it figured out really helps
like you guys know my dad he's a wise
man and and he retired a few years ago
and he it was we were talking about it
and he's like yeah you know now I just
got a I just got to figure out who I am
and I'm just like he's like you never
stopped like you never stop figuring it
out and if my dad in his 60s is still
taking time to figure out who he is like
that's actually really comforting to me
because it's like we get to keep
evolving and keep getting information
about what resonates with us and what
doesn't and she mentioned she went
through a breakup which is actually a
really beautiful time to do
self-reflection because you can be like
okay what did I learn from that what did
I like about it what didn't work what
can I take with me and what can I leave
behind
that's important because quite often we
either try to leave behind everything
including the good stuff that we learned
one of my favorite lyrics is from a band
parlor Hawk who you're familiar with and
Randy lived in Utah for a few years
Aggies I was anyway drew knows an Aggie
Utah State it's a promo for
Oh Logan Utah anyway yeah drew his line
is I learned a lot of good lessons here
that I choose to forget and that's the
problem sometimes we'll go through a
relationship or a career or an event in
our life and we'll learn some lessons
from it and then a few years later
you're like we're intentionally
forgetting those because like we we want
to opt in for the momentary pleasure and
and forsake the lessons we've already
learned sometimes we have to learn the
same lesson over and over to to actually
figure it out before it sticks yeah you
know Shaylee I mean she's a she's a
senior I'm a high school or college I
don't know but I mean if she's in high
school I mean this is this is like her
first experience or one of her first
experiences with going through these
changes and dealing with these feelings
so I know when I was in high school how
big of a deal everything was like
everything was such a big deal and you
know high school kids they do a really
good job of making other high-school
kids lives miserable and you know I
don't know if Shelley is going through
this with her peers or not but that that
pressure of trying to figure out who you
are what you're gonna represent to your
peers in high school I do not miss that
pressure at all so but unfortunately
sometimes we carry that forward right
and we still experience that same
pressure as adults right yeah yeah I
think with Shaylee like the first thing
I would say is Shelley please know and
it's easier it's easier for me to say
this than for her to feel this it is
whatever you do in high school is not a
big deal like it does
you could you could be walking down the
hall and your pants accidently fall down
or you forget to wear your pants to
school you show up and you show up and
underwear I hate those dreams and like
and it doesn't matter I mean you know
I'm 37 years old
God do we I graduated 20 years ago man
that is unbelievable
so graduated 20 years ago and nothing
from high school matters so again my
first piece of advice is Shelley is like
please understand you're young this is
high school things are not as big of a
deal as what we make them out to be
don't put so much pressure on yourself
to be this like perfect high school
student whether it's for your parents or
whether it's for your peers like all you
have to do is be yourself I mean
ultimately with the people we have in
our lives with anyone we have whether
it's a stranger or that's friend family
member we want to trust people that's
what it comes down to and that's what's
important in life it doesn't matter if
you're cool it doesn't matter
you know what drugs you're doing it
doesn't matter what's what sport you're
playing like what really matters
ultimately is can people trust you
Shaylee and the way that you get people
to trust you is you are a genuine person
and you are consistent like that is the
easiest way to gain people's trust so
Shaylee if you if you are having a
problem with figuring out who you want
to be I would start with I would start
with figuring out what your values and
beliefs are because that is going to
help light the path for for the actions
that you're going to take what episode
69 right about yeah yeah so check out
that episode a podcast number 69 but but
from there once you figure out what your
values are once you get clear on what
your beliefs are then from there just be
as genuine as possible and be as
consistent as possible it's funny
because that whole saying act as if I
really I love and I hate that's saying I
love it because it really is true like
it is it's very similar to saying like
you create your own reality yeah I think
do you make it and it's in and I hate it
because it it really I guess it
undermines the importance of being a
genuine person but but that when I think
fake it till you make it what I think is
is like okay I'm Ryan Nicodemus I want
to be a minimalist I want to be a good
example for people what would that
person do so then I start making
decisions off of that and you know what
from day one when I was when we were the
minimalists do I mean so many people so
many people were like Oh Ryan
you're insane we don't know what's
happened to you you're crazy Josh he's
gonna kill himself or something like you
guys are not getting all of his stuff
and that's the telltale sign of
committing
right but eight years later people are
like they've come full circle oh my god
you guys are all supported son
believable but that's only because Josh
and I have been being genuine people
we've been consistent for the last eight
years and like that that is what I guess
made that not makes us qualified but or
experts but uh it just it makes us
relatable I don't know if we're I'm
working for us I think maybe the the way
to a pin that phrase is instead of
active act as if it's act as if your
future self is watching yeah and and
because we are really you look back at
your past stuff like how why did I do
that you know what's funny I'm glad I
did that
so Jordan had this interesting
experience Jordan Jordan no more had
this interesting experience with Jeff
Goldblum and he was at this bar and you
know Jeff he was with his buddies at
Jeff Goldblum over there and his buddies
like oh let me introduce you so he comes
up and he's Jeff Goldblum hey man how's
it going man look at him glasses takes
his glasses off man this is really cool
but so so I mean that Glen I think that
lends itself to acting as if or acting
what your future self wants
so whether Jeff Goldblum is in front of
the camera or whether he is at a party
being introduced to Jordan like he is
being himself
so I being I think maybe the the other
way to talk about it and to frame this
in terms of self-care Randy is is I
think quite often self-care is like
taking care of the best version of
yourself
one thing I'll add to is she did mention
you know her depression and self-harm
and I will say like when I got quote air
quotes diagnosed with depression was in
high school and so it and that was a
really I think that's a really risky
time to throw that on somebody because
there's so many factors that contribute
to mental health and things but the cool
thing is that what does matter in high
school and what can matter for her
whether she's an
school or college is that she can learn
some really tangible tools to take with
her throughout the rest of her life and
so the good thing about my experience in
high school was that putting a label on
it did some harm because I just like
okay I'm a depressed person I'm just
gonna let I literally looked up what
that means and then was like oh I guess
I'm like this you know yeah so that was
dangerous part of it because you're
acting on you've been told label yeah
acting on the label that you yeah but
the plus side of that was that I I
started going to therapy at a young age
and learned some really great things to
help me know myself and to know how to
deal with it and so for her I mean she's
she's really wanting to be intentional
about this phase of her life which is
actually pretty amazing and I and she
gets to really recognize given all that
she's going through that she can even
think this way is pretty amazing but
that she can get help like there's
nothing wrong with that
to work with somebody that you trust and
and and get some tools to know how to
process these things in a healthy way as
you move forward tools can include
simple things like exercise meditation
that is just as important as their yeah
yeah yeah I mean I think I think one of
the things that we're now finding out
about depression is well two things that
that podcast that I mentioned that we'll
link to from dr. Rhonda Patrick the the
antidepressants can be really beneficial
in a short term for certain people and
obviously I'm not a doctor so I lean on
doctors like them to to to guide me
along but but placebo pills have a
better long-term effects of man than
like prozac or or whatever the other
ones are but with this discovery of
rumination and how it creates
inflammation I mean it's it's no wonder
why the placebo actually does a decent
job right and and so so actually you
gotta listen to that podcast it's so
good because especially if you have
suffer from sadness or depression I'm
not I'm not someone who's a depressed
person but I have
- I've had two parents my mother was a
diagnosed depressive and she was
certainly a depressive my father was
manic-depressive and and schizophrenic
and so like there's a lot of mental
illness and in my family for sure and
going through that I realize like part
of it had to do because they did there
was no thoughts of self-care it was all
unintentional self-harm which is sort of
what we do every day is is is the
everyday damage of living a normal life
just creates a certain amount of damage
and Shelley's experiencing that now and
then you pile on top of that what she
said she said she's felt like she feels
like she's held back by expectations her
own expectations and the expectations of
others well what do you think she means
by the expectations like because she has
been known she's been given this labeled
depressive she mentioned self-harm so do
you think that she means expectations
because people don't expect her to keep
harming herself but but because of her
past actions like people who looked like
kind of maybe raising an eyebrow yeah
and I would say my expectations of
myself was probably the biggest like the
most dangerous thought pattern for
myself because there was this also
shaped by the expectations of others
especially yeah with you and Ryan who
grew up in like religious context like
there's a whole other expectation there
as well yeah it's many-layered
because human beings are beautiful that
way but I think it it's like okay there
is the expectations even of school like
you need this assignment done you're
gonna be active in this thing that thing
and then you take that and then you're
like okay well I'm going to now level up
and you think that your expectations are
the actual expectations and so that's
kind of where that I think that danger
lies so she needs to be careful with
what she is expecting of herself and
defining the reality in her mind with
the actual reality of of what is
expected in high school it's just those
expectations we throw I remember being
in high school and the expectations I
throw myself weird I mean I hardly met
any of them like it's such a it's such a
difficult time
I dealt with it ya know I wish I wish I
would add some one answer in this
question for me when I was in high
school I think the thing to note for
Shayla here is a few things one is 99%
of the pressure you feel is internal
pressure its pressure you've created for
yourself there might be external
pressure because there are going to be
external expectations that there will be
especially parents teachers counselors
peers there will be their own
expectations the important thing to note
here you just talked about letting go of
expectations you can't control other
people's expectations and there are
going to be some people who don't like
you but so what no matter what you do
they're probably not going to like you
and even if you do something that is
against what your values are then they
like a person who you're not going to be
yeah it is much better to be a genuine
person and disliked rather than being a
disingenuous person and being liked so
the only set of expectations you can
control then given those circumstances
or your own expectations and measuring
those expectations have certain hopes
there's another way to say expectation
what do you hope for your your future
self yeah I think hope and expectations
are pretty different I mean because
expectations are something that you are
expecting to happen what it's like it's
like you know I hope one day that I'll
have the relationship with my dad that I
want but that is certainly not my
expectation right I think I hope is a
type of X it's a loosely held
expectation yeah yeah yeah and and I
think the difference that I like to
focus on is like what what is the
standard what am I going to do today
that's going to make my future self
proud and so that might mean meditation
sort of self-care ritual so when we walk
out of this question here with Shaylee
what are some things that she can do
what some sort of actionable things that
she can do better take better care of
herself I think to be instead of being
so committed to what everybody else is
going to think like try to transform
that commitment to yourself and really
using this as an opportunity to get to
know yourself really well and that could
be through journaling that could be
through professional help that could be
through you know your daily rituals or
whatever but it's really again embracing
these parts of you that
you wish weren't there asking what can
you learn from them and what can you
take with you as you move forward and
let go of being like okay it's my senior
year I'm gonna be this person or like
come Monday morning I'm gonna be this
person you know for the rest of eternity
yeah and just being like it's a bad
expectation what am I really being
present and what am I feeling right now
what am i learning right now and and and
then just relaxing a little bit and know
that you're just you're just gonna live
your life and you're gonna be how you
how you are yeah dude this is like a
really long-winded way of talking about
lowering expectations and raising
standards so Shaylee needs to lower her
expectations meaning forget others
expectations yes and let other people's
expectations go but she needs to raise
her standards and the way you can raise
your standard it is by it's by
meditating it's by exercising it is by
doing these self-care things that helps
us have reserves so when we do feel
depressed or we have down times that
were not completely drained but yeah man
I don't know how I don't know what to
say to Shay lead to just help her
understand like this high school doesn't
mean [ __ ] like it you know what the cool
cool kids in high school like the ones
that I was so worried about impressing
like they are losers now and no offense
to any of them but like they're still
cool now it's because they they were
never infected by the tyranny of cool
yeah it's not every single cool person
in high school but a lot of just a lot
of the people I looked up to like like
now I look at them and I'm like oh like
you're still in high school yeah not
that high school doesn't mean anything
because at the moment like because it
does but it's like what does this period
of life actually mean I like that better
and that really cling to that and no and
then zoom out and know that this other
stuff okay so yeah and then move forward
you know from what you can gain from it
because every season of life has really
important lessons that's a good point so
it's not that it doesn't mean anything
as much as you have to be very
deliberate with the meaning Shaylee that
you're placing on your on your high
school timer
whatever like that yeah again easier
said than done but yeah I mean I think
right now so what are the important
things with high school it's maybe she
wants to go to college like getting good
grades I guess like water so what are
the important what are the important
takeaways from the high school
experience having fun yes I don't know
yes
socially rule number one have fun not
stressing out about things that you
actually will need to be more mindful of
later but just nurturing friendships
that could carry on with you and having
fun going to a dance you know and just
like being I think that's the one thing
when I look back on my high school
experience I was so busy focusing on my
depression that I didn't realize how
much fun I was having and when I look
back on high school I actually enjoyed
it because I was a theater nerd and you
know we do whatever we want but um but I
couldn't enjoy it in the moment because
I was so focused on everything that was
wrong with me or if this boy liked me or
if I was keeping up with this person and
or what I wasn't being included in and I
really didn't realize that and I think I
have versions of that of every phase in
my life and that's kind of why I'm
really trying to just enjoy as much as I
can now but I think that seasonal life
is to learn and to have fun yeah you
know as much as you can I'm gonna leave
Shelley with a few things to take care
of yourself one thing that I've started
doing recently I guess you could call my
own self care rituals every every week
there's a list of like twelve things
that I make sure I do at least twice a
week and I stopped putting it was
changing my own expectation because a
lot of these things I'm like I want to
do these every single day and it was
reframing my own expectations and so
there's a essay on our website called
the rule of two and basically it's doing
some self-care things twice a week
they're gonna make me a better version
of myself so we'll put a link to that in
the show notes I'll just go through a
few of these but some of its like it's
the free medicine of life that we just
don't even think about going out in the
Sun for at least an hour even if you
live somewhere like where's she from
Washington which is gonna be cold and in
in the winter and gray right but going
out in the Sun is something that is
important even when it's gray there
there is a different experience you're
gonna have then if you're just stuck
under under this sort of fluorescent
cubicles lights or the high school
lights spending time outside in the Sun
is something I make sure I do thankfully
we live in LA and so it's an easy thing
for us to do here but even in Fargo when
it's negative 40 degrees yes you do fund
a lot there's no bad weather just bad
gear right Argo there's no bad weather
just that gear riding is something I
like to do pretty close to every day but
as long as I do it two times a week I
give myself permission to feel really
good I tend to do it five or six days a
week but there are some weeks where it
might just happen twice in fact a couple
weeks ago I know it happened only twice
and I have this this is literally just a
checklist that goes on my phone I print
it out right from my phone this is
stressing me everyone has their own
preferences yeah and so reading a couple
times a week you know I tend to read
usually in the morning sometimes at
night before bed but again it's
something I do more than twice a week
usually and so for me this is I'm doing
all these things anyway and it's a way
for me to say okay am i taking care of
myself but it's also a area for me to
realize where am i deficient because all
these things are happening anyway and so
at the at the end of the day I get to go
and say oh yeah I did this this and this
doing the sauna twice a week I usually
go three sometimes four times a week but
but doing the sauna at least twice a
week I did it last night and I get to
check it off my list I'm doing it anyway
right
stretching or some sort of yoga or
physical therapy twice a week squats
push-ups pull-ups like just bodyweight
exercises cycling meditation that's my
big struggle because it feels so anti
productive learn more about it and learn
what your brain is doing what right and
I think that's the thing where whereas
these other things like you're actually
you're doing something and
is the not doing something that is the
action and so making sure I do that at
least twice a week I'd like to do it
ideally every day but doing that twice a
week getting out and walking for a
couple hours again that's something I do
most days almost every day it's amazing
how a good walk can make you feel better
a nice brisk walk or if I'm really
feeling anxious like going to the sauna
it's changing your state and so in the
short-term these bunch of these
short-term changes leads who to
long-term change as well and I think for
Shaylee it's important to realize like
changing your body especially feeling
sadness or depression one of the best
things you can do to refocus that
anxiety is get some exercise in there
change how you what you're doing with
your physiology that will change your
brain absolutely how many things you got
on the list there there's 12 there's
just 12 what I do each one twice oh I
see I see yeah I was just I was gonna
say like just cut the stress in half of
that list for me but what I was gonna
say is for Shaylee if if she can take on
12 things right now she can write down a
list of 12 or 20 that's and she feels
like she can commit to that that's
awesome but it might just start with
meditation yeah I'm saying it might just
start with a little bit of a healthy
healthier diet little exercise your
go-to thing that you choose from and I
always tell people cuz I do a lot of
one-on-one mentoring with people and
start with something that's super doable
and enjoyable and almost laughable that
you would put it on a list so like going
out in the Sun right it's like why why
would I put that on my calendar that's
literally bad right but that's like
that's where you start like it's gonna
sound silly but that it's you know a lot
of pain and things that have developed
come from these small and simple acts
that we do over time and so I think one
of the best ways to counter that is
through small and simple acts yeah and
so it's like okay
I'm gonna put it on my calendar of going
out in the Sun and if it feels silly but
really fun then you know you're on the
right track of where to start and that
will evolve naturally dude think about
coffee
from the beans that are picked the
region they come from the elevation the
temperature the way that the beans were
transported then they get roasted then
you have you know certain filter you
have a certain method you have a certain
size grind you have a certain water
temperature you have timing you have all
these you know measurements it's like
all of these little things add up to
where like you're drinking a cup of
coffee and it becomes this amazing not
this cup of coffee this coffee sucks but
because I'm just kidding it's that
doesn't suck but it's it's no bandit
coffee which you can get a bandit coffee
company but no seriously it's like well
it's very similar to what you're talking
about
it's like we do think about like yeah
going out in the Sun what's that really
gonna do you know what going out in the
Sun one thing yeah you're not it's not
this magic pill but going out in the Sun
and going on a walk and doing a little
bit of meditation or some breathing
exercises like then you're starting to
add up and it actually is making this
huge difference I feel like is it's not
something to add to your to-do list it's
integrated into how you're living so
it's like okay instead of getting in the
car I'm gonna leave a little bit more
early and walk to wherever I'm going or
when you're working at your desk I would
I talk a lot about desk working and it's
like okay on my phone call I'm gonna
stand up and move around instead of just
sit on the phone call so it's like a lot
of people tell me like self-care
stresses me out or I'm too overwhelmed
and it's when you can really integrate
it into how you're already operating
that's when the magic happens really I
love it I think I think for me the
reason this list was so helpful these
are things I'm already doing but they're
there I've found some like definite
holes where I'm like oh I'm not
meditating as much as I think I am like
it helps you be consistent with these
things yeah and it makes me realize like
I don't have to beat myself up over I
just say oh well you know what I've only
done the song on once this week and it's
the end of the week why don't I just hop
in the sauna yeah and as opposed to
having you know 24 things on a list for
me it's like I've already done these
things and it's a way for me to say okay
like these are the it's a it's the free
medicine that's going to make me a
better
myself yeah it's like if I'd skip the
chiropractor for a month or two like Oh
a sudden I got I start getting this neck
pain and back pain and I'm like oh yeah
like I have a minima chiropractor in two
months and then I go and get adjusted
and you know it helps me out but yeah it
is a great idea man like these things
that we do in our daily lives but
sometimes we just slip for one reason or
another and this is a great reminder I
think ultimately we're talking about
here if you don't if you listen to this
and you're turned off by the term
self-care for me what I've realized is
like it's really just redefining what
success is we talked about trying to
eliminate other people's expectations
because right now quite often our
version of success I know throughout my
entire 20s my version of success was
predicated on what other people thought
successful was it was the luxury cars it
was the house in the suburbs it was the
job title and so redefining success is
important so Shelley I'd love to send
you a copy of our book essential there's
an entire chapter about success in here
which camera Jordan this one okay if
you're watching this on youtube you can
see our book essential Ryan and I wrote
this book it's 150 different essays
about intention of living twelve
different chapters twelve different
areas of intention of living and one of
those is about success or really
redefining what success is for you so
Shawn if you could reach out to Shelley
send to her the audiobook version if you
like our podcast you'll love the
audiobook version of essential or if you
want the book book or the e-book we're
happy to send those to you as well our
next question is from Jeff in Los
Angeles I have a running shoe store but
we do a lot of foot 1us and I see your
thing here on Facebook about self care
and I was just hoping you guys would
cover something about foot care as well
and how that protects to self care
because the feet are our foundation all
right we're gonna skip over Ryan
Tenderfoot Nicodemus here to get Randy
to answer the question yeah yeah I could
definitely use some tips on foot care
Ryan is the most durable person but his
Achilles heel is literally his Achilles
heel and actually I'll tell you the best
advice I ever got when it comes to maybe
it's just posture in general
had to do with my feet we were in Dublin
was 2014 and this dude can't it was um
remember Eric the game-changer the young
kid that was there no you don't know
that I was like anyway so Eric yeah okay
Eric what's up man
so his parents were there his dad came
up to me he's like he's like I am and I
am like you know an expert with posture
he's like your feet he's like they're
too far apart and they're in their gated
he said you need to bring in your gates
and you need to balance on your feet and
it's funny cuz I that is stuck with me
and during talks I actually find myself
and that's kind of an American thing to
like lean on one side yeah like that's
that's a very American posture thing I
have found by focusing on grounding
myself and having balance on my feet
like it helps me give a talk better
helps me pay more attention it's it is
it is unbelievable like how your feet
can really make a difference with your
health that's all I got on feet ladies
and gentlemen so so Randy I was really
hoping to bring you on the podcast to
talk about your feet at some point in
time now you're here I'll tell you this
is the last scene of our documentary
minimalism I so Ryan and I have the same
weird gait even though we were shaped
completely differently and like I have
ridiculously long leather from you dad
the last scene of our documentary like I
cringe every time I see it because it's
us walking away from the camera we're
all walking like ducks but I had to
start going to about three years ago I
start going to physical therapists and
they taught me how we taught me how to
walk correctly and it has totally
changed the way that I walk now and it's
fixed a lot of my back problems a gas Q
therapy was was something was important
because I was walking like a duck and
like quack quack and and what I've
learned over the last three years and I
had to still pay attention to it but
like there's an I had to fix my gait and
I think back to the the the the reason
this question was was interesting and I
picked it is he said something about the
feet being the foundation and I had five
surgeries on my right foot while was my
right big toe specifically when I was
four and 25 I had this terrible ingrown
toenail that kept growing back in and so
eventually they had to take half the
toenail off and kill all the roots and
it's literally the worst pain I've ever
experienced I was gonna say I've never
seen you go through so much pain it was
ten out of ten on a regular basis
unbelievable pain yeah the point was
like I don't know how I'm gonna get
through this next second it was that
level of pain and it it true it truly
like ruined a period of my life because
I when you can't when you when you can't
walk you you feel like you you feel like
you've totaled your life has changed
this thing that we take for granted
every day yeah it has changed I mean and
you know it took a while to fix that
thankfully it's fixed and I try to take
good care of my feet now but it really
is the foundation so Jeff's asking
because he runs a running shoe store but
you know I don't know I I find that like
for me there are all these things that
we take for granted and I'm sure you see
this right now Randy with with a lot of
clients that you work with there are
things they take for granted because
it's funny Jordan was asking me
yesterday she's like so what does Randy
do and I'm like oh how do I explain this
I don't I just throw my hands up I'm
like I don't know water she wears blue
jeans good and well then that's one of
the first things I said like she she
specialized in Thai massage she has a
self-care podcast you can find her
naturally Randi Kaye dot-com all right
we had to think of a quick break there
but we're back but I I do have trouble
sort of explaining what you do because
you are a woman of many hats and how
many hats do you own
27 it's the perfect amount of hat but
I'm sure you deal with a lot of people
who actually have foot problems when
you're dealing with Thai massage stuff
yeah I mean to clarify what I do so I've
been a body worker and yoga teacher for
over 10 years and so most of my daily
work is doing massage and yoga and
helping people with pain and then I do
some online stuff like the podcasts and
some online courses about self-care and
taking care of yourself in general a
foot course I haven't I do have a blog a
long time ago about feet there's a two
part thing about feet it was something
different but I actually do have a lot
to say about feet and this is a tricky
question for me because I feel like we
could have a whole podcast about feet
because there's be the trailer good but
I would say the thing to remember is
that the body works as a whole and
sometimes we get really hyper focused on
one area that's causing us pain and we
forget to look at all the other reasons
it could be in pain and it dysfunction
and especially with the feet a lot of
foot pain are people think they have
plantar fasciitis but it's actually
referral pain from the calves and so if
you work on the calves it helps release
the tension in the feet and so it is
really important to focus on the area of
pain and and modify some things and work
on alignment the style of yoga I'm
trained in and I teach is all alignment
based so it's building something from
the ground up whether it is your feet or
your sitting or something like that it's
making sure you have a balanced
foundation but if you have like tight
hips for example that's gonna make your
feet go outward and so it's like you can
you know add all the support you can or
change your shoes but if your hips are
super tight that's not really gonna help
with the problem so it's really again
and this applies to all types of healing
it's noticing what screaming the loudest
nurturing it but then also zooming out
and seeing how can I address this whole
issue like from a whole body
fact I used to have really crazy tinder
feet as well and it was mainly because
my shins were so tight I wasn't my I
mean my calves are right there next to
my shins
you know this but well I mean they were
so bad that like I had some Rolfing done
and I mean talk about pain oh my gosh
but to talk about relief and and not
only to help my my feet it helped my
gait it helped and it was like long for
those who don't know what real thing is
it's basically just really really really
deep tissue massage it's like it's pain
yes think of painful massage well it is
more like structural integration yeah
and but it is painful and like how long
what kind of increments did you do role
thing because you can't just go an hour
straight no maybe 15 20 minutes but like
I had bruises for a week yeah so it's 15
20 minutes and then do you take like a 5
10 minute break and then get back to it
or is it just you do 15 and 20 minute
sessions yeah yeah and in fact I will
have Bex do it occasionally now where I
her hands aren't strong enough for the
amount of pain that I can tolerate so
I'll have her use her elbow on my shins
and surely bruises as well but like for
me it was it was just that it wasn't
just it wasn't just like where's the
pain its what when I pan out I realized
that the man it's all interconnected you
know my back pain had a lot to do with
my shins and my back pain had a lot to
do with with other areas of my body that
wasn't just my back and I was a couple
weeks out a few years ago from having
back surgery and until I discovered a
gas Q therapy and it was learning to
walk again was part of fixing my back
pain learning just simple weird
exercises with my arms that you know
obviously your shoulders are connected
to your lower back and which is it's all
it's all there but we treat our body
parts as if they're all standing in
different rooms
if you could just take care of my feet
great and that could be a good
short-term thing like to go get a nice
back massage get your shoulders route
like that feels good but that's not
necessarily going to correct the problem
we have to go down to the the we need to
go down a few layers and figure out what
behaviors do I need to change do I need
to correct in order for me to alleviate
some of this pain yeah it's funny like
the chain like the the chain of events
like my so my lower back hurt went to
the massage therapist Meryl was like oh
your thighs are tight your thighs are
tight because your calves are tight your
calves are tight because your feet are
your feet are tight and then you know
it's it's it's just one thing after
another and it seems to like link back
to the feet at a certain point and for
me it also linked back to inflammation
so when I was dealing over the last
couple years dealing with a lot of these
problems that I've had health-wise I was
overly inflamed and I had to do the
summer I did a can long long term fast
and then change my diet considerably to
a fast mimicking diet for a couple
months and reduced my inflammation so
much that I didn't realize how inflamed
I was because I was just living with it
forever sometimes we have that pain and
until it reaches panic level were just
like oh I guess I'll deal with it I
guess this is how life is now yeah and
that's like the good and bad thing about
healing is that you are getting rid of
kind of that numbness and that tolerance
so you become more sensitive to your
pain like my my neck hurts a lot more
now than it did before
when like because I have a healthier
neck so I can notice when things are off
so that's and there is something called
the healing crisis where you like for
example with hips and low back like your
your body is trying to protect itself
it's always trying to balance the
tension throughout your body and so when
it doesn't feel safe it'll like add
tightness here so yeah and so when you
start loosening that up it can feel
really unstable and you'd be like oh my
my low back actually is hurting a little
bit more now but it's like oh well we're
actually kind of rerouting the things so
you sometime
you do feel a little bit worse before
you feel better and it's just constantly
tuning into yourself and recognizing
when you know something really isn't
going well or when you're just kind of
working through something but again it
is looking at the body as a whole is
probably the most important part of
healing pain without overcompensating is
important too I know for me like my TfL
was especially tight and and also like
my glute meat and glute men were so
tight because my sole as was so weak and
and tight and so it was overcompensating
right with these other muscles they were
doing way more work than they were
supposed to now a lot of that has dudes
because I used to sit down for eight to
ten hours a day and and I couldn't do a
single squat like in fact I couldn't do
a bridge well because I remember the
first time I was going to physical
therapy he's like alright now he's
showing me how to do a bridge and he's
like now turn your gluts on and I'm like
what so he had to give me like these
modify the brew is that like a plank no
it's what you lay on your back but you
like sort of thrust your pelvis up in
the air yeah yes I'd love to send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
there's an entire chapter on feet in
here minimalism and feet yeah no
actually there is a I mean the book is
basically about re-establishing our
foundation and so the thing he talked
about is our feet or our foundations and
using that as a metaphor the the thing I
mean it's my favorite thing that we've
ever written and it's this five year
journey of us going from these
suit-and-tie corporate guys to become a
minimalist but in order to do so we had
to really reset our own expectations of
our life what's the societal pressure
was as you said we were leaving the
corporate world Ryan people were like
what you're crazy
in fact people didn't believe me Randi
when I first like quit well the first
thing I did when I quit I told my boss
and he was like you
can't quit you're not allowed and there
was this level of panic that I felt
momentarily like oh my god I didn't
realize he was able to tell me I
couldn't quit I can't I'm not allowed to
quit is that illegal I didn't realize
and ultimately like I had to redefine
what success was like for me I had to
redefine what my expectations were
because I realized they couldn't be
predicated on someone else's expecting
they're like dude were you really going
yeah they're like are you going to AT&T
yeah like it so you're gonna Verizon
right and can you take me with you I'm
like oh you think the grass is greener
on the other side of the fence but it's
the same grass they just put a fence up
here right it's the same exact grass
like no I'm not going anywhere and so I
had to re-establish and Ryan had to
re-establish a foundation in our lives
and and so using that foot as a metaphor
like yeah it is a foundation and but you
need something to stand on in life so
yeah Jeff would love to send you a copy
of everything that remains either the
audio book the book book or the eBook
version of that I apologize there is not
a foot chapter in there all right y'all
we'd love to hear what you have to say
there are footnotes though we'd love to
hear what you have to say so if you have
a comment or tip about feet or self-care
including a vise or any of our callers
today leave us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm will
air our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode and stay tuned to the end
of this week's episode for this week's
listener comments and tips Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it
is time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media we're
on Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists and and Randi Kaye is what
do you add on Instagram
naturally Randy can't naturally Randy K
yet naturally Randy K on Instagram to
find her we're at the minimalists on all
those platforms during the lightning
round this were Ryan and I
now Randy we each do our best to answer
every question which is the short
shareable less than 140 character
response now don't worry Randy we
actually monitor all in a bit as well we
tie it up with a pithy bow and you can
copy and paste our pithy answers on
social media if you like you can find
all of our quotes now in one place
minimal maxims dot-com it's so funny
dude like went on Twitter when I see
people like they'll quote me and I'll
read it I'm like did I say that like man
that is good yeah actually I think
that's what it is I'll say something and
then just edit it I think I think first
and puts it in the show notes all the
middle Maxim's are in the show notes but
then Jess edits it again and puts it on
minimal Maxim's com
Jess Sean thank you for your excellent
editing make me sound smart man me words
really good alrighty round question is
from our first lighting round question
is from Alexa Alexa kill Ryan Nicodemus
calling Ryan Nicodemus how do you
practice self-care without feeling
selfish uh-huh well here's my pithy
answer and then maybe we can we can talk
about a little bit Randy my pithy answer
is self-care and selfish reside on
opposite sides of our values I'd say to
look at I look at cell operating water
in one's own self-interest which is self
care is different from self ish which is
operating to the detriment of other
people yeah how do you differentiate
selfishness from self care brushing your
teeth metaphor so I've heard of this
what is it um it's where you brush your
teeth never heard of you okay mmm
interesting okay okay yeah no like okay
brushing your teeth is something you do
every day
and you benefit from it and the people
around you benefit from it right and so
do you feel guilty for brushing your
teeth do you feel like you're being
selfish like this is really
I knew like a a great way of approaching
these acts of self-care is it something
that you need to do to benefit yourself
and it benefits those around you and you
can't feel from an empty cup right so so
I say my pity and sir is self-care is a
daily brushing of the mind body and soul
how dare you come on here now she'll
make her pit the answer say we could do
a whole podcast about feet my pet the
answer is to give your best to others
you must first give your best to
yourself and just to Josh's point as a
self-care it only becomes selfish when
it is a detriment to others that's what
you need to look at if you are doing
something for yourself and it's making
someone else miserable then maybe you
want to look at that and be like it
might be in selfish right now but
sometimes sometimes here's here's kind
of the tricky part right sometimes it's
self-care that we do it does piss other
people off and they have poor expected
so we've got to be able to differentiate
when someone has a poor expectation or
if we're the ones that have a poor
expectation so that's again easier said
than done like most of the stuff we talk
about but but the more you practice it
the better you get at it for sure and
the interesting thing about that too is
sometimes self-care is a really really
hard decision like the more you develop
a relationship with yourself and I call
it your inner wisdom it it can sometimes
guide you down paths that are really
hard so it could be you know getting a
divorce
yeah you know moving to a new place
that's that's also self-care so it's we
have to be ready to to maybe make some
tough calls sometimes yeah yeah I think
quite often the expectation thing can be
can be so tricky because we don't want
to let other people down but if I'm
letting if I'm if I'm fulfilling other
people's expectations by letting myself
down that's why I have that the
list of my own sort of self-care these
are all individual acts that's a really
good point
so if you are meeting others people's
expectations but it's letting yourself
down like that that's a problem right
and in a weird way that is that's an
involuted kind of selfishness when we're
operating only on the behalf of others
dude I was trying to come up with the
pithy answer something similar to that
because the the it's selfish to not take
care of yourself in a way I think it's
what you're trying to say yeah yeah in a
weird way it's it's pacifying others by
forsaking the things that are most
important to you and it's easy to do
that because we get this little dopamine
rush when we please other people and we
all are people pleasers to a certain
extent but I've realized that you mean
you you guys both were so for those of
you who don't know Randy and and Ryan
they're the same person actually it's
the first time I've ever I've only seen
them in the same in the same room one
since right now I'm actually shocked
you're not the same person but they have
the same personality and identical
personalities and same sense of humor
and and and what I don't know what's
going on they were doing like the EP
finger was oh you like her I got it I'm
just gonna say that I don't know where I
was going with that honestly our next
question is from Ginny all right so
we're moving on to our next question
jenny wants to know how do I draw and
maintain boundaries about what I need
for self-care when others around me are
adept at asking for what they need and
my tendency is to give more than I
receive resulting in me feeling
resentful toward them alright well
here's my opinion sir a life without
boundaries is the most bound life I
think that's also ultimately what I was
getting out with that that previous
question there
is in a weird way we I think about Ella
our five year old she if he we were if
we were to let her do whatever she wants
whenever she wants to do it that's what
we think of as freedom but that's not
real freedom that's a particular kind of
tyranny being able to do whatever you
want whenever you want you can go play
in traffic Ella just have fun no you're
putting up a different kind of bounds
interesting then it's like removing like
the boundaries of like every human day
existence it just makes you aware of
like yeah you're right like you're just
aware of these boundaries that you'll
never be able to reach removing removing
the boundaries of discipline room also
removes your freedom and the the jakka
willing book is discipline equals
freedom and and ultimately that's that's
where we have to go if we want to be if
we want to be free it has to do with
inserting a particular kind of
discipline in our lives and the more
discipline we have the freer we're going
to feel the more accomplished we're
gonna feel now she's jenny is talking
about other people's expectations and
giving giving giving more than she
receives and and for me like I have to
look it and say what are one of the
boundaries so that I can give myself
what I what I need right because without
those boundaries it's back to the Ella
analogy you ultimately you fall off a
cliff or you'll go get hit in traffic if
you're playing in traffic right and so
you do need some sort of boundary if you
want to experience freedom but with too
many boundaries that that's also a
problem right if if you're if you're in
prison literally then you have these
boundaries that you can't escape and and
so I think it really has to do with the
balance of with our with our with our
boundaries now she also talked about
resentment right Ryan yeah and I would
argue that resentment isn't a problem
the resentment is a sign that something
needs to change so that you don't build
resentment yeah
building of resentment is a problem if
you resent something it is it is a
signal it is an indicator that
oh well something needs to change here
because if I keep doing this then
there's going to be a problem mm-hmm
Randy woods here yeah well I guess I'll
start with maybe the answer is if giving
doesn't fill you up then it isn't truly
giving so one thing that I was just in
Peru and Peruvians are amazing people
and really happy and I was just like I
asked him like why are you so happy and
and it and there was a long answer but
the gist of it was their culture is a
giving culture and you you give first
and you share first before you before
you take and there's a lot of joy in
giving and sharing and that was a really
beautiful reminder for me because a lot
of times it's like okay what do I need
what what intentions do I want to put
out there you know me me me but we don't
really think about how to truly give in
in a joyful way and so if you're giving
a lot and you some a lot of people take
a lot of pride in how much they give how
much they serve but they're they're
totally breaking and they don't really
enjoy well you know I got to go to do
this for this person this for this
person yeah and that it's actually
training them I don't believe that's
truly giving because giving is a two-way
street I totally agree well this kind of
goes back to Alexis question to that
yeah same thing can apply there it's
like if you are if you're not taking
care of yourself and you're just taking
care of others and it's to your own
detriment like that is a that's that's a
problem yeah and I like what you said
about resentment being a warning signal
because we do get afraid of that and
yeah engine light in your car yeah yeah
problem is something else but it's it's
taking the time to realize that that's
actually going on as well and otherwise
in builds up yeah and that that is a
huge problem just like the check engine
light comes on you're like well I'll
just put a piece of black tape over it
and that way I don't see the check
engine light anymore that's what we do
in our daily
I feel like yeah absolutely my pet the
answer is this if you keep setting
yourself up for resentment
you're really gonna resent that so so
really you know saying no it's this is a
huge part of self-care yeah being able
to say no no I mean last night I was
supposed to go to a haunted hayride with
Josh and Becks yes Mariah and I were
gonna join we were gonna continue our
tradition of spooky scary stuff in spook
tober but last night like I've just been
getting horrible sleep we recorded a
podcast yesterday I knew I needed to
record a podcast and I'm like I have to
take something off my plate right now
and it's and I wanted to work out I
wanted to ride the bike and I was like
I'm not gonna forsake my exercise just
to go on a haunted hayride so I had to
tell Josh hey dude like I'm not gonna
make it I need to get a good night's
good night's sleep and what do you think
Josh did was he like how dare you cancel
on me the same day I torn up Josh was
very supportive cuz he's my friend
anyone he wants me to take care of
myself and I think that's the key a
couple of things there is you are really
clear on what your needs are and what
your what your main priorities are and
the other thing is that you have
communicated properly with the people in
your life on what those needs are and so
when you say something like that
he totally trusts that that is what you
need and it's not personal and it's
nothing like that and so that's part of
the thing too is you getting clear with
yourself but you also need to have
really clear conversations with the
people that you operate with so they can
be on the same page because most the
people in your life do love you and care
for you and when they really know where
this is coming from they're gonna be
understanding and supportive but when
you keep it all in and then you get mad
at somebody for not understanding you
there's a problem there yeah so it you
have to take it on yourself to educate
the people around you about what you're
changing and and what your needs are so
they can get on board and even like join
you in their own way like a lot of
people with families I work with it's
like let's have you know self-care time
or there's
our in a day where you know mom's gonna
do this and the kids get to do something
that they enjoy and it can turn into
like the culture of the home you know
instead of like I'm taking the time but
nobody cares about what I need you know
so well I think when you when you were
telling someone no whether whether it's
a friend who does and you've said you
know the right expectation so friends
are gonna you know they're gonna
understand because of the expectations
you set up with them like with Josh and
I like he totally like you said he
understood like yes like I needed a good
night of sleep he knows I haven't been
sleeping well so he's gonna support me
because he's my friend and he wants me
to be happy but even you know with
strangers I guess or an acquaintance
that you want to say no to don't just
say no like tell them what you're saying
yes to like yeah explain to them like
the note is or like well I'm actually
doing this right now but maybe at a
later time or whatever there's
definitely an art form of saying no but
also saying yes can be an important act
of self-care as well yeah so so like so
what do you mean by that give me an
example for example um I'll come back to
your example of getting sunshine like
there's been times especially in Fargo
when it is super cold and you've done
your work day and you get home and you
just want to snuggle and do nothing and
sometimes that's great but if you do
that every day it's not and somebody
will invite me to something that I would
actually like but I'm too lazy or I'm
just like comatose state survival and
it's like nah I'm gonna say yes to that
because that's actually something
that'll fill me up so I yes is getting a
bad rep right now but that but there's
also a time and place for that too
absolutely I totally agree with that
brandy thank you so much for being here
and like putting up with my antics and
Josh's antics
we really appreciate we have one more
question if you want to like hang out
yes we have one more question and I'm
looking forward to arguing with both of
you about this how do you practice
self-care when you have so much empathy
what's that all right so if you like to
hear our answer that question you would
hear me argue with Randy and Ryan who
are both very empathetic people I'm
going to present the case
against empathy it's not that Josh is
apathetic he just doesn't know how to
feel he just doesn't have feels yeah no
that's not true no I just don't have a
heart no it's a regular heart you I feel
anxiety when there's coffee running down
the side of Ryan's cup yes that's what I
feel I have no empathy for him though
all right but we're gonna talk about
empathy and the problem with empathy if
you like to hear our answer to that
question you can listen to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively to our patreon supporters so
if you want to support our show and keep
this podcast a hundred percent
advertisement free then head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support in
addition to our weekly PostScript
episodes the minimalist private podcast
feed includes our ask the minimalist
anything episodes we just recorded one
of those yesterday it was really good
unreleased recordings of our live events
we've done 15 live events for our
patreon supporters in the last year you
can find all of those on the minimalist
private podcast feed and also the entire
back catalogue of our past private
episodes we've done over 80 at this
point once you become a supporter you'll
also receive a personal link to our
private podcast feed so that it plays in
your normal podcast player you can find
all the details and all the good stuff
over at the minimalists com a slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode
[Music]
here's the case again sympathy put
plainly in an analogy right you don't
want your doctor to have empathy if you
he's getting ready to operate on you the
literal you don't want him to literally
have empathy if you're you well we were
some about foot care right your foot is
my mom my toe was so messed up right I
didn't want him to literally feel the
pain in my toe yeah of course not I
wanted him to have compassion for me and
so the case against empathy is really a
case for compassion interesting and and
I think when when we experience too much
empathy and this is what M is saying
here she's relating to everyone else's
pain and she is therefore feeling hurt
their pain and how can you take care of
yourself when you're feeling everyone
else's pain okay now it's time for our
added-value portion of the show this is
where you talk about something has added
value to our lives
recently Ryan one has been adding value
to your life well I want to bring Jordan
on here with this beautiful costume come
on out Jordan look at this Halloween
we're just gonna come through the BS
pulled it this is this is like one of
the bits such a simple costume but this
is like one of the best hunter s
Thompson is even your tattoo is like
it's it's a hunter s I love it I love it
dude yeah yeah yeah dude it's funny
after you explained to me your tattoo I
went and watched fear and loathing and I
forgot how much I frickin love that
movie it's so good
so I recommend fear and loathing if you
haven't seen it it's a great movie no we
were just talking about before this
podcast started mariah put on this show
last night called superstore freaking
hilarious man it is so funny but what I
like what I specifically liked about it
we watched two episodes it's a parody of
Walmart basically right yeah it's a
parody of Walmart it's it's a superstore
and it's about the employees and the
management at the superstore and it's
just it's just so it's such a good
parody it's done so this meets Walmart
yeah way yeah in a way it's not because
it's not a diet it's not like a you know
mockumentary
but uh but yeah in a way it is kind of
like that but the reason the reason why
I like this show is because it did such
a good job on this one particular
episode where they wanted to hand out
free samples of this salsa and the
manager he was like I'm just gonna pick
someone random to to hand out samples in
he picks this person out and she's like
is it because I'm latina is that why
you're picking me to hand out the salsa
and he's like no no he's like okay fine
you know have to do almost pick someone
else random and then he goes to the
other there's only one other latina that
works there
so he goes of that one but it's this
whole episode on where like she was
totally okay with handing out this salsa
and then she in fact she's like talking
to customers and she is like creating
this faux Spanish accent and the woman
who was a fent who was offended by the
boss picking her like it was this whole
you know this whole scene where she's
like I can't believe you're doing this
this is our people but then by the end
of the episode she's doing the same
exact thing and it's just funny like how
they took this this really sensitive
subject because we are you know in
especially in the States like we are
douchey with like how we you know
represent certain cultures and it's it
is it can be a sensitive subject but
they've been able to take like something
like that
and create this hilarious episode and
you actually learn something from it was
it's the the Kafka line about how life's
most serious and sensitive topics can be
discussed only through jokes and humor
right yeah and and it's the reason that
you have something like South Park or
the the Book of Mormon like the musical
right that's not a parody are you sure
sixties dark humor the the irenna snow
yeah the musical but like I really love
the Mormon response to that was like to
buy the full-page ads and the the
initial playbook or play the bill or
whatever and it's it's discussing rather
sensitive topics that is really charged
if you try to have a debate about
Mormonism exactly
about about cultural appropriation when
you have debates about those it becomes
charge but when South Park or Homer
Simpson is doing it all of a sudden it's
like oh I can at least see this through
the lens of humor yeah it makes it less
it's a serious thing but it makes it a
little less serious and it makes you
approachable yeah sci-fi you just put it
in space and you can do Star Trek The
Next Generation
really Green watching they touch on so
many sensitive subjects so like you
wouldn't even think about but you're
right because because they're in outer
space whatever you want well for my
added value portion I'm going to talk
about two things one is Randy's podcast
it's the simple self care podcast she
did a couple of conversations one with
my own partner Beck's and so they had a
conversation put a link to that the show
us and also Jessica the gal who works
with us a social media manager and
all-around outstanding person jessica
lynn williams and you did a podcast with
her twice my first second timer uh-huh
well we'll put links you to both of
those put a link to your website as well
naturally Randi Kaye dot-com and then
also there is an album that I've been
listening to this new yeah the new Cat
Power album came out a couple weeks ago
oh man I've not checked it out yet I
can't wait to listen to it it's called
wanderer and I think well in the episode
and a little bit here with the title
track it's the first first song on the
album called wanderer cool Randy has
anything but adding value to your life
recently yeah so a couple of things I've
been thinking about just because I just
I'm traveling right now there's an app
called calm which is a relatively new
app but I use it a lot at home it's got
a lot of really good meditations it has
music like calming music on there and
you can you know put in what you're
looking for in duration or whatever but
my favorite part of it is they have
bedtime stories and they're read by like
out of use even fry and like the most
soothing voices ever so there's one I've
been listening to my husband and I
listen to them a lot going to bed but
the there's one that I've been listening
to over and over
and so I downloaded it for offline mode
and I was listening to it on the plane
when I had a red-eye or even last night
when I got in late and I just was so
grateful I had this like sweet little
bedtime story about lavender growing in
France so that helped like trigger that
sleep response so Mariah and I have been
we've been trying to do well we
attempted it for like a week but it
wasn't really working we were trying to
do audiobooks but I'd get too engaged
right exactly and it's only like 20 30
minutes I usually don't make it to the
end yeah
the other thing I'll add is that I'm I
don't I have a travel lightly I don't
like to have a lot of extra stuff when I
do I know but my husband's really into
tech and gadgets and I am always like I
don't need that but he's like take these
what's it called sound soundproof
headphones yeah and he put it like he
tested it out on me before I laughed and
I was like whoa and then and so I had
these with me in a plane they are the
Bose and do they play an ambient noise I
think no they're just literally noise
cancelling yeah there's no electronics
in them no that the technology you think
whatever you want on them yeah you can
takes a lot of whatever noise okay white
noise whatever but on the airplane so
much traveling and I don't know what it
is about people but they love to play
videos without headphones and airports
that's unbelievable it just loves my
mind these people should be a wreck it's
it's noise pollution and it's like it
really bothers me so if you're a person
who listens to your phone out on
speakerphone mode in public or your or
worse like your tabbing a full
conversation on speakerphone with your
phone in front of you yes yeah oh or
you're listening to music or watching
videos not being inconsiderate [ __ ]
the people around you control your
headphones so I it's bulky to care
says little like whatever but they have
been a total lifesavers so I love those
all right well Shana finally propose
we'll put a link to those in the show
notes as well let's move on the right
here right now I'm gonna skip most of
these because we're running over on time
but uh I just say thanks to Randy I
appreciate you being here
I'm really grateful you're awesome if
folks want to find out more about you I
think your website is probably the best
place you can follow you on all the
socials from there yep and it's just
naturally Randi Kaye com Randy with an
IDE we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well if you want to comment on
this episode you can do so on youtube if
you want the show notes in your email
inbox just go to the minimalists comm
and you can enter your email address at
the top we'll never send you any spam
because that stuff is gross but we will
send you any new show notes any new
writings from the minimalist as well
it's quite a few new essays on our
website as well the minimalists com Ryan
you got anything else for us I have some
liver Randy hey Randy I want you to
check out these voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi josh and ryan
is becky from england just sending a
voice message for all those people who
are still struggling with family members
buying them gifts even though they've
asked not to receive physical gifts so
i've been listening to the podcast i
think for a year and a bit now and so i
actually went back recently listened to
all your old podcasts right it's the
very beginning and it seems like it's a
recurring question recurring problem
that people send in time and time again
is i'm getting really frustrated with
family members keep buying me things
even though we've told them that were
minimalist and i just wanted to share a
recipe of hope really as someone who has
reached that turning point i think two
years or whatever into my minimalist
journey the penny has finally dropped
with family members and friends and they
finally get it and that is how long it
can take and i think it can even take
even longer and because people have got
a whole lifetime lifetime's worth of
habits to shift they've been buying you
gifts you know your whole life so we've
just been accepting gifts and smiling
and sort of explaining that we're you
know embracing a minimalist lifestyle
and that we live with
and sharing our message but trying to
not get frustrated and you know donating
those gifts on and it's felt like we've
sent a lot of gifts to two charity shops
and donated them on I mean a lot a lot
of gifts and I was starting to get even
more frustrated but this year we've
really reached our turning point where
people have stopped buying us things and
so it was just a message of hope really
to tell people to hold on and have
patience and have faith that it's gonna
happen eventually because it can just
take time and I think when we first
discovered the minimalists I remember I
was so pumped like was so happy to see
all these changes in my life and we're
so excited to do all these things
overnight like wake up the next morning
and throw out belongings and we kind of
want everybody to do it with the same
speed and it just takes everyone around
us a lot longer I think to adjust to
that and I kinda didn't realize that at
the time so it was just to share that
advice onto any other new listeners who
are struggling with that that give it
give it time because it will happen
eventually
hey minimalist my name's Emma Romo and
calling from Memphis California a kind
with a tip for people who don't have
enough space now I don't mean go out and
get storage or anything like that but my
husband and I recently moved into a
Motorhome we live in an area where we
have four seasons spring summer fall and
winter and so we have a lot of clothes
that change with the season in our new
RV however we don't have a lot of room
to keep our clothes that we need for
those different seasons and getting rid
of them would just be ineffective and a
waste of money and irresponsible with
our money so what I've done is I've
purchased two airtight Vince one for my
husband and one for myself we keep our
fall clothes or winter clothes in these
bins fold it up with space bags if
necessary for some of the bulkier items
like snow pants or snowboard jacket and
gloves of course and long-sleeve
sweaters shirts etc that we won't be
wearing during the summertime I come the
winner will pull these out when we need
them and we can flop in the summertime
it's really important to make sure you
don't get carried away
and just use this as an excuse to keep
all your clothes even though you don't
really need them but if you have limited
space and you need these kinds of gear
for different seasons this is a great
option
hi this is channeling and I'm calling
from Heber Utah about the most recent
podcast episode 136 it's mementos I had
a comment for your two colors that were
asking about emotions being attached to
things and wanting to know if they could
get rid of I think it was children's
clothing that was the one lady was
keeping stuff that she'd gotten from her
dad I think the other one anyway um I
had a couple of thoughts with this
mighty youngest Sunday when he was
almost 2 and there's a lot of emotion
involved with that and there were a lot
of things that we're difficult and one
of those was cleaning up his room and
cleaning a lot of stuff we moved about a
year after he died and so I had to go
through and pack all the things and in
his bed German at the time I did not
have the energy or the ability to decide
what I wanted to keep and what I wanted
to get rid of so I just packed
everything that we had I'm gonna fit in
a couple of small totes and it moved
with us once and then again a year and a
half later it moved with us again and I
knew that they were there and they were
in the little toast but I did not touch
them did not open them did not look at
them and find me about oh it was
probably about six years after he died I
decided that I needed to go through that
stuff and so I went to the basement
which is where we put all of our stuff
that we don't want to look at and I
opened up the coats and started to go
through them and I realized about
halfway through the first one that I was
still very emotionally attached to most
of the items in there so I told myself
that I didn't have to get rid of
anything and I sat down and I just
looked at everything and kind of process
the emotions that were involved and
attached to these toys and these books
and these clothing these pieces of
clothing that we that we could get and
then about a year later I felt like I
could go through them and to determine
what I wanted to keep and I ended up
donating almost everything and we pulled
it I think a couple of outfits
and one or two toys for my other
children do you use this mementos and we
have little shadow bucks that we need
that has a couple of twenties and a pair
of shoes I think of his but everything
else we ended up donating and when I was
ready to go through that stuff and I was
ready to let it go it was very peaceful
and it was very easy for me to identify
where I wanted to keep him what I wanted
to get rid of so I guess my caution
would be if you still have a lot of the
emotion tied up in the clothing and you
feel ambivalent about it it's okay not
to get rid of it all at once all right
so that's it for this episode if you
have a question for the minimalists give
us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message we hope what's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all Randy thanks
again for being here and we'll see you
later alright look so let's check out
this track from cat power it's the title
track from wanderer unless you're on
YouTube then we'll be in a link or
something click here
and minimus